but the world champion has the white
pieces in this game here we go and it's
an english opening maybe a homage to us
here in the studio but uh magnus he does
play pretty much every opening there is
and okay shaq reacting in what we call
the reverse sicilian type of way and
black's bishop coming out very early
white knight jumping forward to hit that
black bishop which does retreat and this
is a rare variation actually which i
used to play myself when i was very
young but it's uh it's experienced a
resurgence this line very popular lately
i lost you when uh when you were a baby
in in this in this variation at the isle
of man and uh i also had this with the
white pieces about uh two weeks ago in
the reykjavik open
a great great competition you know so
very lovely lovely place iceland a bit
like norway i'd say similar cold it was
right it was sunny i actually sat
outside at some point in a beer garden
really i believe it yeah it was it was
nice did you try the did you the lagoons
the i didn't really i was too busy
losing a chest to have an opportunity to
try them but yeah as david says this
this is a quite a well-known variation
where this is a key move that magnus has
played um and i think alexei shiroff um
a player very aggressive player was one
of the first people to play this line
with the black pieces uh but white now
has the bishop pair which magnus loves
he loves having the two bishops yep
white has the bishop pair so long term
that will be a huge factor i was about
to say shaq in return has a great pawn
center but this last trade
i'm very very surprised by i must say
maybe i'm not quite up to date here with
the opening theory maybe this is kind of
advocated by computers but usually as
black you want to close the position
because your opponent has the bishops
right here the bishops uh coming to life
later on instead trading pawns opening
lines will help those pieces later so
okay surprising it is surprising and i'm
just checking the engine to see whether
it's the top choice it actually is a
little bit of the top choice uh other
moves are actually developing the light
square bishop but uh in terms of human
games in the database
no one plays it yeah okay it's very
positionally dubious as you say david
because
when you're playing against the two
bishops as black is white has the two
bishops bishops are like arrows they
they shoot across the board and you want
to keep them closed in you want to keep
them inside you don't want to let the
arrows come out into the open fields and
by playing like this you're allowing
that that the bishops to to play
so i think the only justification i can
think of is that black has to use his
pieces quickly and maybe try to break in
the center with some quick push to open
it up because white's not castled yet
yep so black does have a small lead in
peace development black has already got
his king to safety black does have pawns
that he can throw forward for example
the white knight in the centre of the
board looks nice and pretty but black
can kick that away with a pawn on the
next turn so maybe black is just trying
to gain a bit of speed uh gain tempe as
we call it in chess when you gain
several moves in a row and
yeah maybe magnus still has the problem
of how to develop magnus needs two moves
to castle the white king and shaq in the
meantime clearly with the help of
preparation just judging by the speed
with which he's moved
yeah shaq will be trying to push forward
and okay the rook move prepares a pawn
push in the center shack trying to blow
up in the center over the next few turns
he's playing uh super fast so far as
shakira and mamjarov the first game
ended in a draw let's uh quickly hear
what shaq said to savada after that game
it must shock but then the magnet seemed
to liquidate quite well
yeah it looks slightly better maybe it's
a good advantage for white but after
i don't know i just want to play some
good moves but
it was
too long i mean to play e4 or something
rp4 i don't know it looks
very good position for white
but okay i mean i think it's a good
defense and
is it a good feeling to at least be
pressing in the first game already
of course when you play with white is
normal i mean
yeah it's good thank you thanks
it's good it's good says shakti mama
they are here in game two with the black
pieces is it a good start to this game
for him
yes but uh still very early days i think
shaq will be very happy with his result
in game one if he can hold this game as
well but uh if he ends up losing this
one
black now against magnus then yeah it
will look like great match strategy from
the world champion i mean while a couple
of moves white did indeed castle as
predicted and now black is gaining some
time against this white knight in the
middle that white knight now has to step
back most likely and then black is going
to break in the center should we explore
what's about to happen simon because it
could liven up any moment now
yeah definitely i mean the the white
knight is attacked um let's say you
bring it forwards because i i'd love to
reroute it to the best square and the
idea of this i want to come back and
then control outposts i'm always looking
for squares
that can't be controlled by my
opponent's pawns
and
the whole point of this though is that
black now has the opportunity to break
and he gets rid of that kind of
backwards pawn you call it because it
can be defended that hole in front of
the pawn and he breaks and this is this
is the point behind shaq's opening play
let's say you have an exchange of pawns
here it looks as good as anything the
white the the black knight comes in
and now you've got to say well that's a
lovely black knight in the middle look
at the black rook the black rook is
lined up against the queen
and it seems that black's pieces which
are not doing much at the moment they're
all lying at home on the queen side but
they can quickly come out and this this
is clearly the idea uh hoping to get
some equal position uh white also a
little bit cramped here but he does have
the two bishops
temporarily at least this bishop is
asleep and doesn't have a great square
ivanka you surprised by this one this
night retreat instead
i'm not entirely surprised because that
was my first reaction as well i don't
know why i timidly thought about
retreating but i did i mean the main
thing that i could see is that when
black breaks out white has to find a
great hiding place for the queen because
you know if she gets kicked around
it's going to be super unpleasant with
all the extra time that black is getting
and already for example if you try to
develop this piece which is asleep if
you try and bring it forward once the
breakout does happen then it's ivanka's
point where is this queen going to sit
no matter where she goes she might get
kicked around if you move forward you
might get hit by one of the black
knights
kind of if you slide just one square to
the side then you're still in the way of
the two rooks you want to connect your
rooks in the middle game that's just a
very
good rule to live by but now black's
pieces come to life black occupies all
the light squares and actually these two
bishops are not impressive at all so uh
yeah maybe great opening preparation by
shaq magnus down on the clock already
significantly more than five minutes and
he just has to try and stop this
breakout this pawn push it's about to
happen and if it does happen black is
doing well so in your chess talk with uh
mamajara of ivanka
i guess it becomes obvious he started
quite late with chess
so david said in the start of this game
that magnus often with the white pieces
is quite dominant against structured
is that a result of him starting with
chess late that he's not that good in
the opening or
no i i don't necessarily think so
because you know during the chess talk
he kind of said how incredibly hard he
he worked i think it's just a reflection
more on like magnus's cult magnus's
insane talent you know he is a legend
you know probably the best person to
have ever played chas ever but uh you
know and also you know mama jared was
also pretty honest you know that uh
before in the past he was working 10
hours a day now
maybe only three four hours
and uh mustn't forget that shakira
is slightly older than magnus yep by i
think
six years i want to say yeah six seven
years old seven years yeah
and also i think shaq when he was a bit
younger he was a bit fragile just
emotionally at the board
i think that's one of his strengths of
being emotional kind of playing very
human type of moves and playing on the
opponent's weaknesses but i remember so
many games where he resigned early
often against magnus even he would have
a slight disadvantage he just gives up
and moves on to the next game but the
older he gets okay maybe he works less
hard on chess now maybe he's less kind
of tactically sharp as he used to be but
he's more at least kind of
psychologically strong so now bouncing
back from defeat he's capable we've seen
him in this tournament end days very
very strongly um he's still a great
player and now some of the previous
weaknesses have become strengths i'm
just wondering if magnus has missed an
idea here sorry to just go back to the
position but you both mentioned how the
white queen was struggling to to find a
square so the white queen has tried to
find somewhere safe but how about we
bring the black bishop out to line up
against it a very logical move and uh
maybe i suspect not but maybe magnus's
idea here was to bring his bishop uh in
line with that to try to break that kind
of it's a weird placement of pieces on
that diagonal
um and actually maybe this this could be
the idea maybe this is actually all
right for magnus this at the moment
maybe this is what he's relying on uh
but it just seems that majority has got
his prepping he's got his uh he's got
his ideas in and he must be comfortable
here but yeah this this must be the idea
actually maybe it does work for magnus
it's actually very rare to see a
complete diagonal occupied like this
yeah every single piece every single
square sorry on this diagonal it's
occupied by a pawn or a piece and uh
there's a lot of tension here especially
behind the bishops you know the move i
wanted to play there i know the move you
want to say you wanted to give up your
room
i wanted to go night a five but it is
day day whatever and i'm starting to
blunder my pieces now and i suddenly
realized oh dear hang on a minute that's
not a very good idea because you lose a
piece this would be a winning move for
black hitting the queen and hitting the
bishop first you mentioned unfortunately
this white bishop does go those pieces
drop off
and they do so uh ambitious
hallucination
you know um we saw magnus lose in that
way against jordan van forest i mean
it's those kind of it's actually those
bishops that are hiding away and nearly
on their starting squares they're
difficult they're difficult to spot them
the range of them and yeah definitely an
exciting position and i love the
geometry of the position every single
piece occupying a long diagonal very
very rare and definitely a tense tense
position and
once again
you guys have been awesome with the
selfies and i just wanted to share with
you a few selfies because festeem is uh
watching the show and watching the chess
whilst boarding the plane and he just
can't miss this game shaq against magnus
i mean that's uh i'll tell you funny a
funny story was i i have a youtube
channel and
uh someone said you got me in so much
trouble at the office and i was like
what do you mean and uh when i do my
youtube videos i can get quite animated
so if i play a winning move i could be
like yeah yeah come on get in there my
son and uh he was in the office and he's
on his little break and he left the
sound on
so all of a sudden there's this male
shouting yeah yeah get in there son and
everyone in the office was like what's
going on it's a chess video it's a chess
video oh no and they didn't and they
didn't believe him so i got in trouble
there oh no anyway so you've got to be
careful watching streams on the plane if
he leaves the sound on yeah you know
with this it could uh he could get
thrown off the plane also happened uh
when i was playing in gibraltar and i
was trying to it was deep in thoughts
and when one of the tournament
organizers walks in and he's and he has
your stream on the ipad and he's walking
around and i guess oh really i can push
your voice and i'm like oh no
turn away quickly
turn away quickly yeah and yeah just i
mean the bishop move has happened uh
white's bishop now we're expecting it to
go and kind of block up that whole
diagonal challenge black's rook in the
centre of the board just to finish uh
talking about your youtube channel simon
um i once went into
a prison in england just to talk to some
of the inmates about chess and they have
a really great chess club going on there
i mean it's uh it's really great to see
the passion for chess and i was talking
to them and they said they get one hour
internet per week and one of them one of
the inmates there he said he spends it
watching simon uh the ginger gm's
youtube channel apparently i'm very
popular in prisons
i've heard that before i think that were
yourself um with their cake stealing
what is funny about kaiya i nearly got
arrested today
since the deja vu
so i i had breakfast i was being i was
meeting a friend in town well i thought
i was going to get rested and i got on
the tube had my coffee started getting
on the tube chilling out it's only a
couple of stops then i saw at the end of
the tube a ticket man coming and i
thought oh no i've forgotten to get a
ticket and he's coming near an era and
i'm like what do i do oh yeah the phone
the phone so i'm downloading the app and
he's like getting a little bit nearer
tickets come on come on up get a little
bit nearer come on there's a ticket and
it's like yeah there you go
just got there in time so he was very
slow checking the people i had to down i
had the app i just had to buy the ticket
yeah
hopefully that bodes well for more drama
on the board as well
[Laughter]
sure so you know
community services dramatic also travel
here before simon williams is starting
to get dramatic on the board david it is
because white's last move was actually
really really provocative white's dark
square bishop moved out the way so look
at the tension on that diagonal the
white queen
okay it has been occupied now this
diagonal i was about to say the white
queen was about to come under heavy fire
but uh with this last move magnus is
attacking black's rook in the center and
shaq we see his screen he's hovering
over the black rook in the middle of the
board he's about to retreat it one
square
we could see some trades but either way
look at how much tension there is in the
middle of the board all the minor pieces
all the knights the bishops they've just
gravitated towards each other either
we're going to see a lot of trades or we
might even see some tactics where one
side may win a piece one side might
sacrifice to build up an attack
the evaluation bar also on black side
just
to me as well instinct-wise it feels
like somehow it should be pretty decent
for black this position because black's
knights are so centralized so strong but
uh it's all about concrete calculation
now can shaq break through he's got time
advantage as well
it's looking maybe a bit scary for the
world champion and his many fans and
it's definitely dramatic in other games
going on right now in the oslo esports
arena as well look at the bar in game
two with anish giri and pragnanda
it's all the way over to inisha's side
is prague about to go down two points
it's looking difficult for him he's
stuck in a bad end game and giri he's
great in those types of positions so uh
prague in trouble so prag in trouble in
the tournament situation as well because
look at liam leia the bar is over to his
side in game two against jordan
phanfories liam he won the first game as
well and if he wins in the rapid portion
today he has chances to win the
tournament
and so does young christoph duda the bar
is over to his side as well in game two
against eric hanson winning game one
duda on the same point score as liam lea
if he wins on the rapid portion chances
to win the tournament and remember if
you are watching us on twitch you can
actually follow all the games at the
same time there is a command center and
you can design your very own show and
follow exactly the games that you want
to one of them four of them whatever you
want we are paying our attention to this
game
magnus carlsen against
shakriyad mama diyarov and mamadiarov is
in deep thought so let's head out to the
lounge choose survivor because i think
someone who knows what the shakriad is
thinking about is out there with swara
yeah i'm actually standing here with uh
shakira's manager and uh first of all
it's it's how are you feeling about
being here in oslo now and being at this
tournament we're very happy to be here
uh this is first time i'm in oslo also
chakra as well he used to be in
stavanger and in tromso but not in oslo
the format of the tournament itself is
also very interesting actually it's kind
of the new uh
digitalization of the chess and in a new
global life generally we're very happy
to be here well but it's been fun to
watch the chakra here i was
lucky enough to be able to to join you
guys yesterday to the chess pub here in
oslo the good night and and really
seeing how shakira interacts with other
people with with the chess community
here and and he's such a people person
he's a very some simple person in
general he likes a very social
socializing let's say
you know i was working in the chess club
in baku in 2000 from 2005. i met him
there he was quite over the famous
person a famous chess player and
whenever he was coming to the chess club
all kids were around him he was playing
with them
all the time showing them the some
variations or some i don't know games of
himself and so on and
i have very nice pictures from old times
i've even shared with kaya recently by
the way probably she will show it
it's interesting because he's really
been offering a lot i was fortunate
enough to be at this pub with them
yesterday i got to play my three minute
games against his 10 seconds of course i
kept losing but it's really someone who
offers from himself to the chess
community and he's got such a great
sense of humor but he's also comes from
this quite humble background i mean he
grew up in
a very small apartment 40 square meters
together with with with his whole family
and had to sneak out to play chess do
you think this has made him a more
humble and a more appreciative player
well
five people in one small apartment it's
not easy
uh unfortunately he was not coming from
the rich family let's say and um
therefore
he tried he did his best and he worked
on himself too much to achieve some
level on his life
which goes to show that it is actually
possible well if you're if you got the
brilliance of shakira mom and dad of
which not that many people do it is
actually possible to make it even in
such a competitive background where it
usually takes so many resources
what a story he has and uh it sounds
like a lot of fun down at the good night
yesterday with swagger shakti everyone
was there to enjoy an evening and maybe
it was a good idea for shakira to go
down to celebrate his match win
yesterday because he's playing some good
chess today he's playing some good chess
and on the last turn he did trade a set
of pieces i was about to say before that
i really liked how the game was turning
in black's favor in shaq's favor but now
with this offer of a rook trade the
question is
once the rooks come off i'm expecting
magnus now to bring his other rook to
the center once they come off who is
going to win that end game if it's just
queens on the board or if it's just
coins and knights on the board
does black have winning chances if
anyone i prefer black here because black
has connected pawns on the left side
white has isolated pawns shattered pawns
on that left flank
what do we think here winning chances
for shaq yeah definitely um let's uh
forget that he's facing magnus carlsen
the world's probably best in-game player
but you know in a normal game i think
definitely there is chances for magnus
to go wrong and like you say it's just
to do with uh white's bad pawn structure
and i think minimal risk here for shaq
as well white has a four versus three
advantage on the right half of the board
but that is very hard to push if white
pushes any pawns in front of his own
king then there could be danger queens
and knights will combine and uh okay
instead
the white queen's stepping back so
magnus he's in defensive mode again
but we were just discussing this a
moment ago
magnus he might be in a must-win
situation in this match because liam is
winning his match and if liam wins in
the rapid section
magnus if he doesn't win in the rapid
section liam is going to overtake him
liam beat him in their heads ahead and
that's the tiebreaker
it's uh oh my wow yeah i mean liam's
played fantastically well and he's
actually got a very good tie break
because he's been a couple of the key
people in the head-to-head battles so
he's he's an outside card at the moment
because he's not uh at the top but the
way the match is going he could steal it
at the finishing line uh and he he has
you know he's an ex blitz world champion
he's a fantastic player and uh you know
and he's such a nice guy as well just
the way very humble very easy to chat to
and we always root for those kind of
guys and remember that was the day that
magnus was really unwell really ill and
liam beat him and
also there was a big mouse slip in one
of those games and maybe that would
decide the fate of the title this game
is looking anything but a win for magnus
carson all the rooks did leave the board
as we predicted and look at this mama
jarv he's getting ready to start
creeping forward with those black pawns
and what is white doing in the meantime
white has centralized the queen very
typical of magnus carlsen centralizing
his queen the white knight looking good
but not much influence on that left half
of the board black has an easy plan of
pushing pawns
magnus on the defensive again yeah maybe
it's now time for the white queen to
switch roles and uh instead of
centralized
being centralized you can maybe just uh
switch over to the left and start
twitter that's a horrible track
oh no i fell for it major trap major
traffic okay we have to show that one
because uh yeah
yeah so here the black pawns are about
to start uh moving forward mobilizing
and this wouldn't be great for white for
example if white's king steps forward we
might see a trade of pawns and black has
an easy route to a past spawn later
maybe this will decide the game and okay
magnus doesn't fall for the trick but it
would have been very natural to try and
stop this pawn push with the white queen
swinging it across but this is why you
always have to look for checks and
captures in every position a check would
have hit the king hit the knight as well
it looks like white can solve both of
those problems by stepping forward but
always look for captures every position
queen takes knight is a check
giving up your queen but luring the
white king forward in to the path of the
black knight this is a check and
actually on the next turn no matter
where the white king goes the queen will
drop off black emerges with an extra
knight and magnus he's played a similar
idea but he saw that trap he didn't fall
for it instead he retreated his queen
same idea to stop this black pawn
marching forward but at least now
preventing the black queen from coming
down to deliver a check white's queen is
covering that key square
yeah i fell for that trap hook line and
sinker understandable it's a very easy
trap to fall into the and magnus of
course spotted it but uh mere mortals
might have made that big mistake
bringing the queen over so the queen
coming back now i'm expecting shaq to
move his knight just uh i'm not sure
where backwards forwards any square just
to defend his pawns over here he can
play it slow as well there's no
immediate rush for shaq
and okay he retreats his knight also
very very natural
and uh magnus now knowing him he'll step
forward with his king or maybe push his
pawn forward uh actually maybe pushing
the pawn forward now just to control the
black knight jumping
that would be very logical and uh yeah
very tense end game magnus can he work
his magic he needs to start winning now
yeah and it looks like
pregnant
could be about to be out of it if he
loses now game two against geary as well
then the best he can hope for is two
points winning in
tie breaks and winning the two final
rapid games
and uh it's yeah
it's looking difficult now for prague
yeah he looks
done for in that end game giri covering
his head with his hands normally that's
a sign that giri isn't doing so well but
this time on the board giri's in full
control barring a miracle for prague see
much more focused today anish just the
fact that after his win he went out um
and he was offered the chance for an
interview and that's the first time i've
seen anish turn down an interview after
he wins so ever
ever yeah he's normally very happy to go
and speak um to whoever's asking him but
this time it's like no and i think i
think in some ways that shows that he's
he's really up for this one you know he
he wants to finish on a win which is
kind of bad news for prague yes it's
much better playing out to form people
uh especially someone as strong as a
niche it can be quite liberating just
playing the spoiler role just
giri he could just sit back relax spoil
prague's tournament uh kind of have an
influence on the destiny of the title
but
um yeah for prague of course it's
it's a very very
sad situation for prague because you
know he's been playing so well
in these uh previous matchups i also
have another theory
so the first time first day i didn't
have breakfast with anish
and he won and then the other two days i
had breakfast with anish he lost so i
thought oh no no
us play a chess player is a little bit
superstitious so i'm going to stay away
but i was still in the same room
and he lost he did better he won he lost
on tie breaks
and today i decided i'm not actually
going to go to breakfast
it's a bit dramatic
and uh yeah i decided no breakfast and
uh yeah he's doing well it's very noble
of you sacrificing your food
i didn't sacrifice my food i had i had
uh i had a burrito
from last night did you have it you
didn't have any cake though
no
i was gonna bring eric some cake in
today and i forgot
no
it's gone wrong for eric on the board oh
no i should have brought his cake in you
brought a cake no i was going to
remember yesterday i was saying i think
eric needs a bit of cake because he was
a bit upset yesterday
i forgot to bring him a bit of cake in
okay i have to buy him a beer instead
and shots and yeah looks like a man who
needs either cake or a beer jerry
canson's struggling today as well it's
been a difficult few days for eric
hanson
meanwhile a big big decision in the
magnus carlson game he's just gone for a
queen trade and traditional wisdom would
say don't go for a queen trade in this
position because black has the potential
for what we call an outside pass pawn
you remember the three versus two
advantage black has here on the left
side of the board but
okay surprising as well why not bring
the black king towards the center
because now white knight can jump into
the middle of the board very surprised
by that last move because uh taking the
king was much more natural
to stop white's knight now coming
towards the queen side these these
endings i find incredibly tricky to play
myself because
it's so hard to predict how knights move
around like a bishop pretty
straightforward they're pretty
straightforward people like accountants
or something and knights are i don't
know what is a night they're like really
tricky they're like musicians aren't
they they're jumping about everywhere
so politicians
are slippery oh i don't i think they're
a bit nicer than politicians yeah yeah
yeah obviously especially english
politicians
got it let's not even go there no
there's not okay there but um yeah but
it's very tricky ending to play but i
mean here it comes yeah the knights come
in
and the only only justification for
black is that the black king is going to
reroute itself and snake towards that
white knight uh try to destabilize it
and magnus look at what he's doing with
the white four pawns there yeah i was
gonna say this one could turn because
it's that three versus two advantage
that black has on the left side it's
always better to have outside passports
away from your opponent's king because
then your opponent needs to go all the
way over and deflect distract their own
pieces
um i would far rather be black here i
must say that queen trade just shocked
me took me a bit by surprise and i mean
black's knight is very bad isn't he he
has to
re-route that night i guess uh at the
moment but you're correct i mean if you
can get a past pawn as well it's a bit
of pressure much easier for black to do
that get it past pawn uh okay um but
magnus ending you know he's pretty good
at these he is very good and uh yeah
well he has to
step backwards i think with the knights
i think it's way too risky to step
forward if you go forward
you might get trapped it's going to get
trapped right do you want to get your
pieces trapped behind enemy lines no no
no no no so step back to the d3 square
and then
continue the game on from there i mean
magnus is doing all the right things
though you know we talk about past pawns
that's that's the aim of the end game
you know either to check mate the king
or to promote your past pawns and uh
there you go but it was a reluctant move
though we saw magnus just kind of
sigh exhale just thinking i have to
retreat it's not ideal
also while you guys were discussing the
politicians magnus visibly shook his
head a couple of times so he's not too
happy at all that he's landed in the
same game maybe he's aware in the back
of his mind that liam if he wins his
match
forces magnus to try and win in the
rapid
section and he's not going to win this
game barring
a massive turnaround it feels like it's
a two result game black is the one
trying to win this one white just trying
to kind of line up the pawns creative
barrier
and yeah i mean yeah i mean those white
pawns though they could they could
slowly come forwards and you know i
wouldn't rule magnus out
potentially uh you know he could he
could still win this game
and his pawns all the white pawns on the
king's side where the king is they're
all ready just to step forward bit by
bit and that
one one great tactic when you're playing
against knights i like what shaq is
doing here rerouting that knight to find
some targets but one brilliant idea is
to try to restrict your opponent's
knight with your pawns so if you can use
your pawns to take away the squares your
opponents night just by moving them up
slowly uh you should nearly always do so
but that black knight now coming to a
better square yeah this is the pattern
to remember if your opponent has a
knight on the sixth rank then put your
pawns on the third rank opposite it and
uh you will dominate that night uh for
example the knight can't jump into the
square or the square because white's
pawn controls it completely that's why
shaq has to retreat and this is actually
a common theme that we see in openings
middle games and end games knights
dominated by pawns forcing uh the
knights to go and look for fresher
pastures and actually this is quite a
nice maneuver as you mentioned there
simon
this pawn is very loose white does have
these two icelandies as we call them
isolated pawns
pepper armies
[Laughter]
is there a tactical opportunity yeah
yeah white stepping forward pushing a
pawn and this one is extremely risky i
would never even have dreamed of looking
at this move i must say because even if
you win a pawn as white you've given
your opponent the best thing in night
end games now
black temporarily a porn up white
getting greedy grabbing a pawn but it's
all about these guys and okay white
blocks these pawns i was about to say
knights are terrible really bad at
stopping these corner pawns because
knights could only stop them from one
side a pawn in the center knights can
stop from any part of the board but
pawn's on the side of the board knights
are terrible at stopping them and magnus
he's blocked he's hoping that these two
pawns are not
that great they are doubled and
meanwhile white has a majority on the
other side and white has a passport here
but if black can now somehow challenge
this knight i'm thinking kind of coming
round this way maybe uh to start
challenging this white knight
he's doing it he's going through his
fear for oh he's here for magnus here
look at the bar it's so i mean in
endings having the outside past pawn as
david said pawn on the side of the board
in night endings in king and pawn
endings is nearly always winning yeah
and uh the idea of just swapping nights
off um
i don't think magnus can swap knights i
mean i think that would just be simply a
losing ending unless
i don't know i don't think he can anyway
yeah just to show simon because if white
plays the most natural move bringing the
white king towards the center then this
is what we're trying to say swapping the
knights off yes white has a lot of pawns
here but this pawn is simply going to
act as a distraction uh for the white
king for example no matter what white
does this is just game over immediately
if the knights come off the board one
pawn distracts the white king and while
the white king is distracted dealing
with this pawn the black king has a free
ride to go and capture all of white's
pawns this one is simply game over if
the knights come off and magnus he's
realizing in the current position this
is almost a winning plan now for
shakaria offering that night trade
magnus in massive trouble i i didn't
expect any of the results that are
happening today to happen
i think i thought magnus was gonna
cruise uh with the score against shaq
he's actually struggling especially in
this game prague is is uh not having
well he's having a terrible day and uh
duder and liam are putting the pressure
on so
anyone anyone can still win this
competition magnus avoiding the exchange
of knights there yeah magnus also
flicked in the pawn check if the black
king had taken white's pawn in the
center of the board white would have won
a knight so um things are changing but
it's all about that black pawn on the
edge of the board will that black pawn
cost white his knight it's going to be
hard to stop it white's knight at the
very maximum is going to be left as a
pure blockader white's essentially going
to be playing without a piece
that trick you mentioned earlier pushing
that pawn forward jamanca
it crossed my mind i just ruled it out
immediately i just thought you cannot
ever give your opponent a pawn like this
but maybe magnus was trying to win yeah
maybe he was just going for a win maybe
it's the tournament situation that's
getting to his head well maybe he just
got excited you know because he saw that
hey he could capture a pawn and
sometimes we're not looking at the
la the bigger picture and uh yeah
shakurya advancing the a pawn and now
the black knight has ideas for example
of going to sacrifice itself to
challenge white tonight just to distract
the white knight away from that black
pawn maybe squares away from promotion
now maybe you can show this david
because in this position now on the
board and they're both getting a little
bit short time black can play this idea
of going knight to the square a4 and the
point is if you get a queen that's what
you're trying to do in the ending you
win the game and you're trying to dive
white's knight away from the defense of
that square so after the capture the
black pawn goes forwards and there's no
way you can cover that black pawn
becoming a queen so little ideas like
this this the problem with a knight
against a side pawn a pawn on the side
is you can only defend it from one side
of the board you can't move the knight
off the board to defend it from that
side in the central pawn you can defend
it from both sides so the knight is
really lacking squares to to stop that
pawn and i i i probably just think that
black's completely winning i think so
too you know also the problem is as well
is that the white king is going to have
to be
distracted um distracted to the left as
well to kind of hold the position and uh
i love the move that you suggest i think
it's a great great opportunity big
question is if the knight comes to the
edge of the board whether white can just
defend his night with his king and again
we talk about king and paul nang games
it just depends now the white king is
inside the box as we call it stopping
this black pawn you call it the box
because you can kind of draw a box where
this pawn lies and as long as your king
is between here then you can stop the
pawn so the king is within distance of
this black pawn and the black king if it
marches forward suddenly it has to deal
with white pawns as well in the center
so it could become a porn race and it's
not clear who this favors and so maybe
that's the question yeah yeah yeah i
totally agree um if white can just
defend his knight
with his king then there's no reason to
put your knight on the edge of the board
so mama jarv may be just looking for an
alternative route with a black knight
but the evaluation bar says winning for
black that means there's something
strong now and my majority has around
five minutes to find it i have a feeling
it's about moving this black knight just
to clear it out the way somewhere for
the black king to come forward but i'm
not sure what the best square that's
what shaq is trying to figure out i
agree with you i think that's probably
the winning plan you want to keep your
knight defending white's potential pass
pawn this is the strategy and you're the
black king can then come in that route
you mentioned david just towards the
other area of the board and the simple
strategy you can even give the black
knights up for the white pawn uh because
you've got that wing pawn you've got the
past past me in a pawn that can't be
blocked the past pawn on the side of the
board and he has done the similar idea
he's moved the knight to block it and
now the black king is ready to come
forwards this looks very clever because
it looks a bit scary at first you've put
your knight in range of white's pawns
but after the pawn steps forward okay
we'll see a trade for example and now
the black knight just moves you move you
attack this white pawn gain some time
and if the white king steps forward to
defend it then you just leave your
knight as a defender now the black king
marches forward this is exactly what
we're talking about knights are easily
going to stop these two white
centralized pawns
because uh centralized pawns you can
keep a handle on them from either side
of the board this knight is never going
to be able to fight against this black
pawn black has a winning position here
you're just going to march down munch on
this pawn munch on the white knight and
promote your own pawn later okay it's
winning completely winning now for shaq
and uh let's go back to the players this
is actually the position on the board
and i think magnus crashed to defeat
there's not even a trick here i mean if
we bring up the analysis board quickly
uh i would like to play my e pawn
forwards uh with one idea
i want to get past porn if you go pawn
takes pawn okay then i can go f6 yeah
push freddy and that pawn now becomes
very dangerous but the position look at
magnus the position the white king was
just too bad there if we just quickly go
back uh before we go to magnus's move
yeah um instead of taking that pawn uh
you could have just taken the other one
with check
and that's just crushing and this check
is is the winning move but back to the
game i have this looks horrible now how
can you ever move those pawns yeah look
at this knight it's a perfect blockader
you're never going to promote either of
these two white pawns and uh okay white
is just gonna sit still and hope and
pray but
yeah i mean black's knight at some point
can even go after these guys maybe on
this flank uh imagine if you get this
pawn running and this pawn running later
it's just gonna be a dream for black so
it's just about where black can put his
king first of all and then he'll
activate the black knight and i think
it's worth bearing in mind that if
magnus loses this game very very likely
he has to win the next two right to win
probably the way the tournament's going
yeah to win in
to definitely win in the rapid portion
he uh will have to
it's just so chaotic right now look at
that yeah just lost liam led just lost
game two to jordan van freeze that means
they are tied
in their match and liam is that player
that won the match against magnus so if
they were on the same score
liam would win but now it's all chaotic
but duda is still the bar over to his
side and if duda wins
with three points and magnus wins in tie
breaks
magnus is the champion and uh we can
look back to that one f3 move that
happened all the way day one game two
yeah better head to head score that's
the tie break in this event but now we
have to talk about magnus losing in the
rapid portion shakira mamadara could be
about to go up a point in this match
magnus loses in the rapid portion his
chances are over and i think duda or
liam will win the tournament and okay
mahmoud of going back with the black
king this is really clever he's going to
move the black knight out of the way
next and the black king is going to go
after white's central pawns white's
pawns are all fixed you can barely touch
any of them meanwhile no matter what you
do here is white it just takes too long
to go after black's pawns on the edge of
the board and we talk about double pawns
sometimes if you look on the a file
black has one very far advanced pass
pawn but even if you win it black has
another pawn to replace it later
i just can't see magnus saving this game
i'm so surprised he's looking so calm
because normally in this type of
scenario magnus would be
shaking his hair super expressive maybe
he doesn't realize how bad it is
or maybe he knows but he's hoping that
mamajarov gets nervous yeah i mean i'd
be amazed i mean
yeah if he didn't realize here how how
bad his position was i mean
you know he's probably the best endgame
player of all time uh magnus carson and
well he's getting outplayed in the
ending here yeah which is which is i
mean let's just think how impressive
that is for mama jaroff yeah i mean he's
done this jordan uh but he's doing it to
the best end game player of all time
that's really
really special that is uh definitely i i
think magnus just looking at the screen
i think he knows that it's super bad but
he also knows that he has to be 100
focused if he is going to save this game
yep and meanwhile manager of just
blocking the advance of white's pawn
that makes a lot of sense just
maintaining the status quo
and uh magnus how is he going to
survive this one
i don't think white can ever really play
for the win again unless black
completely loses control unless mamadar
miscalculates maybe the clock times
they're around level maybe the clock
will play a big factor in the end of
this game magnus has to just maybe up
the pace put shaq under pressure on the
clock
white's king has to move you can't
really touch the white knight which is
forced to guard that black pawn
no more pawn pushers for white processes
of elimination you have to move the
white king do you move the white king up
towards the center or do you move the
white king over towards that black pawn
you have to calculate it's going to come
to a race either way
oh dear this is a complicated one isn't
it you know
running with the king to the right side
feels so scary and okay the computer
says there are only okay two or three
good moves here all of them pretty bad
for white anyway and uh yeah the top two
moves are king moves that's what we
mentioned you don't really want to move
your knight but moving the white knight
to go and block black's extra pawn on
that left side it's the third choice i
doubt we'll see that one it just looks
terrible decentralizing the white knight
it's all about whether the white king
can step into the center and that's the
computer's top choice the white king
moving to the e4 square
behind its own pawns i think i think
with the last move i mean again we could
maybe bring up the analysis ball very
quickly let's say white does move the
knight to block the pawn um which is one
idea you can maybe try to go for the
other pawn with the knight and you can
get two past winged pawns by checking
the king the king moves and now you
attack the harry porn
but we have a lot of moves on the board
so that maybe was majora's idea we do
and magnus is just waiting he's sitting
and waiting he brought his king forward
the black king started dancing towards
this pawn and magnus has just stepped
back so his whole idea is that if the
black king continues marching then white
is going to try and set up a blockade i
think by bringing the white knight back
stopping the black king's access to this
square and white's king also blocks its
access to this square still looks
terrible to be honest the black knight
jumping forward but maybe if the black
knight gets too distracted and starts
grabbing this pawn then the white pawn
mark might march
so really complicated position
dramatic um liam he has finished his
game with a loss and out in the lounge
with spider he did have some thoughts
about what's happening on the these
other boards let's hear from liam
prague is a bit in the trouble in his
his match magnus is struggling now in
his second game against uh
chakriad you're suddenly in the
discussion does this create extra extra
nerves
no not really as i said i will just
focus on my games and whatever happens
happens thank you thank you
so i'm not focusing too much on this he
is tied with you didn't we did have a
few moves is magnus
heading for a loss what's happening
maybe he's finding a sneaky way to
defend uh shakurya has given white a few
moves so white's king it was in the
center of the board just three or four
moves ago now it's all the way down and
now the white king is going to take over
the knights roll the white king is going
to stop the black pawns and the white
knight is free and ivanka you think that
maybe magnus has found a miracle save
yeah i mean i was thinking that now that
the white knight is free to roam the
board it can actually start looking at
the target at the f7 target and uh
just restrain black's forces there
yeah so again we have to jump in because
this is getting really critical now the
black king wants to march into the
center taking the white pawns but this
would be met uh possibly by a night
check and uh suddenly the black king
once it takes this pawn would drop a
pawn of its own suddenly things are
disappearing and maybe white is getting
closer to the draw depending on whether
he can eliminate all of black's pawns
but instead of this king move we saw
shaq jump in with the black knight
hitting this pawn and white going after
the black pawns himself
and we mentioned wing pawns being the
key
is okay evaluation while swinging though
is uh magnus going to be able to
eliminate this pawn start muching his
own pawn forward or has shaq got this
one under control
i mean i'm struggling to calculate here
taking this pawn taking this pawn
yeah you can uh yeah
i think you i'm sorry i just saw a kind
of an idea for white to how to eliminate
most of the dangerous pawns so you take
the i don't know just say you take the
airport yeah white also returns the
favor and so you come
forward with a king yeah
maybe the idea for white is you just
kind of leave this structure and now
black is running out of pawns so you
just march forward with your king and
eliminate these guys maybe magnus with
this idea can eliminate black's pawns i
don't like what shaq has done and
advanced this pawn because it's within
range now and okay things are heating up
both sides around the one minute mark
this knight check is aimed at taking
these pawns all in a row but suddenly
this black pawn is dropping i think
maybe magnus is going to save this wow
and at the same time look at the bar in
a geary prague game too it's uh down to
the middle so maybe prague is also back
in the mix now saving a draw in that
game wow miracle save my prac a miracle
saved by magnus both on the cards now
both of them still fighting for the draw
i don't think either will win but
momentum change every move every moment
wow the drama on this final day you guys
magnus carlsen fighting to save
a draw in this game too
and uh snapping on their heels is the
young christophe duda of course who's
won his second game against eric hanson
so yeah judah is basically about to win
that match and gain all three points
putting so much pressure on magnus and
prague
to win the tournament yeah magnus and
prague they know they have to win their
match whether that's
in rapid format or in the tie breaks
and uh yeah magnus
once he finishes this game he'll realize
the other results and how dramatic it is
but uh he needs to save this game first
one minute now for magnus carlsen low on
the clock
and still the white pawns are about to
drop off the black king is about to get
really really active i mean i think if
if white can just get rid of the one
black pawn around the three black pawns
he should be all right um because
you see where the white king is the
white king is now perfectly placed to
blockade those pawns on the side of the
board
but can he get rid of that pawn i'm not
sure he can where's he going with the
white knight and
this is very peculiar uh why he's gone
this way because that that pawn now
behind the black king
is is gonna just run up the board and
try to become a queen so i'm i'm very i
i mean to be honest night endings as i
said they just confuse me so much magnus
is getting nervous he just changed his
mind three or four times you saw his
computer screen he clicked on his king
he eventually did play that move but he
changed his mind he was about to bring
the white knight forward instead what
about a check now what about can you go
pawn check or am i missing something
just to uh the night can't be taken here
so just just try to and he has it he's
checked the king the white king has to
go back otherwise that black pawn would
have promoted now this is a free move
for for black and now he can advance the
king and start motoring with the f-pawn
i think magnus is in serious serious
danger he's losing he's complete he
didn't get rid of that f-pawn that was
the problem the pawn near the black king
he had to go for that pawn and i think
that pawn is now going to start coming
up the board
i think you said it the other day with
two bishops
it was the two pawns what was the saying
it was uh bishop can't dance at two
weddings yeah maybe it's pawns as well
or porn pawns can dance at two weddings
does that work
oh really does it no no it doesn't work
at all it's not quite the same but you
can't stop both those points a night
can't stop two yeah two weddings just
about the placement of the kings as well
white king is just an eternal defensive
piece it can never join the action again
those two black pawns on the left side
they completely lock down the white king
black is playing with an extra king and
look at this he's just going after
white's pawn and it's all about that
black f-pawn as you said he's kept it in
reserve he's never touched it so far
major of that black f-born but he's
going to start pushing it down the board
soon and here we go it's rolling yeah
and it's going to cost white his knight
how is white ever going to find a way
out of this uh dilemma
it's not what's just going to push this
game over total total
lost you know here for magnus
pushes again though
and there we go have we seen a result i
think magnus has just resigned
and uh
there we go yeah big result for the
tournament standings massive result what
a resolve by shaq black pieces yeah with
the white pieces magnus crawls and loses
this game to shakarya and mamadira that
means he is down by one point in the
match with only two